thank you hey
thanks a lot well it's good to be here
and i'm having a good time i'm uh
watching a lot of tv do you enjoy
watching the tv
and my favorite thing to watch is star
search that's my favorite show man
that's a good show with ed mcmahon and
you know what's good about that show you
get to see the stars of tomorrow
today you don't have to
you have to wait around
till tomorrow
so uh
and i love my favorite part you know is
when ed mcmahon introduces the uh junior
dancers you know when he does that he
always has this like uh
hot property
[Laughter]
a bunch of kids come dancing out there
too cute for you
uh
i also like that cause they got junior
dancers on it too and you never see
junior dancers anywhere else in show
business you know it's only on that show
you never where the hell is
now i mean you're never hanging around
go hey honey what do you want to do
tonight maybe go down at a bar there or
catch a movie or something or uh hey i
know i i heard about this new joint down
on 6th street they got uh
they got the five-year-olds dancing i'm
really good at that
i understand hot property is going to be
there tonight we can see them i never
seen them live i hear they're better
lives than
on the
tv they're even better
and that's also a big mistake they make
on star search they always name their
groups like hot property and stuff like
that as if that's going to help them win
you know what kind of
like the bands it's always like some
embarrassing intro you know i was like
ed be gone our next group
has been kicking around the miami area
for the last 16 years
now america say hello to
overnight success
[Applause]
that looks lame if you lose with a name
like that you know you don't look good
so now it's time for the judge's
decision
do you see the judges on star search too
how lame judges are they yeah
you never heard of the guy you always
got some
suspicious credentials there you never
heard you know i was like now it's time
to meet our judges
he is the president
of tri-media artists
and he represents such stars as
meadowlark lemon
there he is
he's a bald guy with glasses
then they cut to a ball guy with glasses
but uh no so you know you want the good
names you know you don't want the the oh
the guys the bad names get the winning
you know the guys with the big goodness
i was like now it's time for another
tough decision for our judges
another tough decision for our judges
our challenges
overnight success receive
one and a quarter stars
but uh
and i like when uh ed like brings them
over that's my favorite part like when
the guy that wins you know han over here
overnight success let's pretend they win
you know
and then they run over you know and then
sometimes ed has some good news for him
that's my favorite part he'll go
overnight success well it's good to see
you there and
how would you like if i told you
you're in the semi-finals
okay hey folks i'm going to go over
there now thanks a lot huh talk to you
later
norm mcdonald's here
we were really uh we were enjoying your
bit especially over here your stand-up
because andy was a judge on star search
yes i was
like
andy is the andy is the president of
tristar entertainment yeah that's right
that's the california guy i'm talking
about
hey
they love each other
how can we need more of on tv what am i
doing
okay how are you how are you doing
you're doing a great job thanks a lot
well i try to you know make it funny and
stuff and uh
and that's your secret yeah
you know what you got to do you got to
keep in track of the competition that's
what i find you know see what they're
doing and try to make it funnier than
them so like i brought uh some jokes i
do and then some jokes that you know you
might hear from the competition you know
okay so here's the al cowlings you know
this guy yeah so my joke was al callings
now has a 1 900 number for 299 a minute
cowlings will tell callers that oj is
innocent for 399 dollars a minute he'll
try to do it without laughing
i like that joke yeah well they don't
now
compare this with uh this was uh tom
brokaw's joke you know your earlier
guest yeah yeah
this was his joke the same night ac
cowlings the man who drove o.j simpson's
bronco as police followed today came out
with his own 1 900 number
nbc's david bloom has more
not even funny you know it's like
it's like the lamest yeah no it's kind
of late joke i've ever heard in my life
now here's another one here
twin daughters have been born to andrew
and carrie kennedy cuomo this one two
weeks ago making former new york
governor mario cuomo a grandfather
the girls were named pataki and sucks
so that was my job that's your joke
that's a good joke
here we go now here's broca okay the guy
that they're paying all these millions
to
he says mario cuomo is a grandfather
today
nbc's jim bitterman has more
it's like it's like almost exactly the
same joke as his other one
it changed the guy's name all right
what's he doing
right thank you
yeah
you hold on to those andy
those will come in very handy i figured
it out because i saw a show you know
what the problem is he's got guys in the
background typing they're typing stories
and he's already doing the news it's
like too late you know what the hell's
he thinking
uh
let him start a half hour earlier and
get off a half hour earlier
you'd have a better i don't know
all right well how are you i see you're
in uh you're in billy uh what is it
billy madison
adam's movie the other day yeah how was
that you're a movie star now yeah i know
um
i'm just in that movie with that
well what's it like working on a film
yeah it was great it was great to uh
uh work with adam you know i uh
i never met him that was the odd part in
the whole movie you think i'd have a
chance to meet the guy uh-huh
never never came up
you don't seem around sarah not live at
all no i never see him he's not
we never crossed pads
one of those things people think these
guys these
audience people they think everybody in
show business knows everybody that's
right they're idiots
[Laughter]
he didn't mean anyone here no no no no
no or anyone watching at home no no no
you didn't mean anything like that no no
no you guys aren't idiots you know that
you don't have to have me tell you
you're not idiots for god's sake
but you're not you're not idiots
i got i
i got you out of that whole fight he
went back that one guy is an idiot over
there
yeah yeah we've had problems with him
all right
[Applause]
all right
who's on santa live this week what is it
it's george clooney and the cranberries
is that right yes that's what it says on
this card george clooney and the
cranberries yeah that'll be a fun show
to watch yeah try some broken material
when you're out there okay all right
well i'll be looking forward to it okay
buddy
thanks for coming